scuola e digitale due parole che non
sempre suonano molto armoniose da un
lato immaginata infatti il mondo
frenetico e velocissimo della rete delle
nuove tecnologie
dall'altro pensate alla realtà
decisamente diversa della scuola
italiana fatta ancora in tanti casi di
aule poco connesse di attrezzature non
sempre adeguate di competenze digitali
non scontate due mondi che quindi
sembrano quasi muoversi a velocità
diverse tutto sta però cambiando nella
scuola italiana con i suoi tempi ma sta
cambiando e sta cambiando anche e
soprattutto grazie ai docenti che sono
sempre più connessi e sempre più
coinvolti per condividere idee e
metodologie strumenti
ecco per chi come me si occupa di creare
strumenti digitali per la scuola
questo scambio e confronto costante che
c'è oggi tra gli insegnanti è davvero
una fonte inesauribile per nuove idee ed
è anche l'occasione per interrogarsi su
un aspetto a mio avviso fondamentale
tutti questi strumenti che stanno
entrando nella scuola e non parlo solo
di tablet o di lavagne multimediali ma
anche di robotica di stampanti 3d delle
infinite up che oggi esistono anche per
fare didattica
ecco tutti questi strumenti nella loro
semplicità di strumenti sono solo un
modo per rendere diciamo più
coinvolgenti e interattive le elezioni o
possono essere anche un'occasione
preziosa per far conoscere più da vicino
ai ragazzi il mondo digitale che li
circonda far conoscere quindi i
meccanismi più profondi del web e delle
nuove tecnologie
parlando di diritti e di doveri di
rischi ma anche di enormi potenzialità
sto parlando del concetto di
cittadinanza digitale e della necessità
che la scuola educhi futuri cittadini
che sappiano usare la tecnologia in
maniera competente consapevole e anche
creativa
se è vero come si dice che tanti bambini
che ci sono in questo momento la scuola
primaria da grande faranno un lavoro che
ancora non è stato inventato
beh io credo che puntare sulla
creatività anche digitale sia una
questione fondamentale
tutto questo però senza dimenticare le
difficoltà che tuttora vi sono nel
parlare di digitale nella scuola
riuscita infatti a immaginare
concretamente un docente oggi alle prese
con il grande tema della scuola digitale
qualche tempo fa per rappresentare in
maniera anche ironica questo insegnante
ideale con alcuni docenti
ho creato un personaggio emblematico ve
lo presento il professor santo digitale
allora senza grosse pretese artistiche
il fumetto è una modalità creativa e
narrativa che utilizziamo molto per
raccontare la nostra idea di scuola ed è
anche una mia una mia passione bene chi
è il professor santo di vitale beh
sicuramente è un insegnante che è
convinto dell'utilità di introdurre la
tecnologia all'interno della didattica
convinto della necessità se volete anche
morale di insegnare i propri ragazzi a
utilizzare in maniera responsabile
questa tecnologia
cosa può fare concretamente con gli
strumenti digitali tantissime cose può
ad esempio creare una mappa concettuale
su qualsiasi argomento disciplinare può
utilizzare uno strumento inclusivo ad
esempio un app per la lettura automatica
dei testi può proporre dei contenuti di
approfondimento perché no anche un video
ecco può fare tantissime cose
il nostro professore però non è
semplicemente un professore è anche un
discreto atleta che cosa significa
significa che
decidere oggi per un insegnante di
introdurre il digitale nella didattica
in tantissimi casi significa lanciarsi
in una imprevedibile e ardita corsa ad
ostacoli
gli ostacoli possono essere i più
disparati la connettività sicuramente la
presenza o meno di strumenti digitali
all'interno delle scuole
il divieto che in tanti casi persiste
nel far utilizzare i dispositivi
elettronici ai ragazzi mille altre
ancora oltre questi vi sono poi gli
ostacoli forse meno tangibili ma non
meno insidiosi e mi riferisco agli
equivoci fraintendimenti alle resistenze
alle diffidenze che vi sono tuttora nel
parlare di didattica digitale
c'è infatti chi può sostenere che tutti
questi strumenti in fin dei conti non
siano altro che fonti di distrazione o
peggio ancora che possano in qualche
modo compromettere le capacità di
apprendimento dei ragazzi
ecco di fronte a queste posizioni
in realtà va sempre evidenziato che
siamo scuola per cui l'utilizzo di uno
strumento di qualsiasi strumento
digitale o no è evidente che all'interno
di un progetto educativo ed è un uso non
certo un abuso
il docente che avete visto per come lo
abbiamo immaginato non è sicuramente un
fanatico del digitale a tutti i costi né
io personalmente ne ho mai incontrati
pur girando tanto tra le scuole o invece
incontrato molti insegnanti che
insistevano su questo aspetto di educare
ad e tecnologie viste anche come
possibilità soprattutto per gli studenti
per creare dei contenuti non solo per
recepirli passivamente prima infatti vi
ho fatto vedere qualche semplice esempio
di cosa può fare un docente con la
tecnologia ma pensate a cosa possono
fare gli studenti anche con i loro
dispositivi di tutti i giorni che a ben
vedere sono strumenti potentissimi per
effettuare ricerche per consultare
dizionario online per creare contenuti
video presentazioni
animazioni qualsiasi cosa e chiaro che
prima devo insegnare ai ragazzi a
utilizzare la tecnologia di tutti i
giorni
anche per questi scopi ecco pensando un
po ai tanti professori santo digitale
sparpagliati nelle scuole di tutta
italia qualche anno fa abbiamo lanciato
il nostro progetto per la scuola a
fidenza che cosa abbiamo creato in
sostanza abbiamo creato un social
network per la scuola un social network
didattico social network didattica mi
rendo conto che possano sembrare due
termini un po lontani in alcuni casi
forse antagonisti però sapete con le
giuste accortezze i meccanismi
comunicativi e collaborativi delle
piattaforme sociali possono essere molto
efficaci in un contesto di classe come
funziona in sostanza questo strumento
il professore accede e crea una classe
virtuale ad esempio la terza c
preciso che classe virtuale non è nulla
che si sostituisce alla classe reale
piuttosto è qualcosa che accompagna e
arricchisce le lezioni in presenza
potete immaginarla come il gruppo di un
qualsiasi social network con la
differenza che qua se viene un ambiente
protetto
ci sono solo docenti e studenti e
abbiamo tutta una serie di funzionalità
specifiche per la didattica che cosa può
fare questo insegnante ovviamente a una
bacheca dove può inserire dei contenuti
un video una dispensa un link può
chiaramente inviare messaggi e
comunicazioni alla sua classe dialogando
in tempo reale con gli studenti può
segnare delle attività test e verifiche
sicuramente ma anche lavori di gruppo
ricerche lavori condivise all'interno di
uno stesso documento tante altre cose
ovviamente poi il vantaggio che gli
studenti in qualsiasi momento ritrovano
in piattaforma tutto questo materiale
lo possono consultare come quando
vogliono quindi anche nel rispetto dei
vari tempi e stili di apprendimento bene
fin qui è uno strumento
utile innovativo pur sempre uno
strumento in che misura può diventare
un'occasione per parlare di cittadinanza
digitale
beh la classe virtuale che avete visto a
tutti gli effetti è uno spazio reale uno
spazio dove lo studente non deve solo
svolgere le attività che vengono
disposte dai propri insegnanti deve
imparare anche a relazionarsi con gli
altri con i compagni di classe e con i
propri insegnanti deve imparare a
dialogare online evitando in qualsiasi
modo atteggiamenti ostili derisori o
conflittuali deve imparare a collaborare
quindi ad aver rispetto degli altri
esattamente come lo deve avere nelle
relazioni diciamo offline
ecco questo aspetto dell'educazione ai
media quindi sapersi comportare in rete
è evidentemente un aspetto fondamentale
per crescere gli adulti di domani
se poi io insegnante chiedo ai miei
ragazzi di effettuare una ricerca online
e di condividere i risultati di
piattaforma beh sicuramente deve
insegnare a individuare i contenuti più
pertinenti e diciamo veritieri
ma allo stesso tempo deve insegnare
anche utilizzarli e riutilizzarli
correttamente ad esempio nel rispetto
del copyright o delle varie licenze
d'uso
ecco sono solo alcuni degli esempi dei
temi fondamentali di cittadinanza che la
scuola può affrontare parlando di
digitale e utilizzando strumenti anche
come quelli che vi ho fatto vedere
ovviamente non solo però sono tutti
strumenti che possono servire deve
quindi uscire un po dall'insistenza
sugli aspetti meramente negativi del web
e delle tecnologie e puntare più sulla
consapevolezza spiegare quindi i
rapporti che vi sono tra vita reale e
vita virtuale spiegare l'importanza
della collaborazione della condivisione
anche in un ambiente virtuale insegnare
anche a utilizzare in maniera
equilibrata tutti questi dispositivi che
indubbiamente hanno scombussolato le
nostre vite adesso bisogna imparare a
gestirli infine la creatività io credo
che il digitale renda molto più vicine e
accessibili tante modalità espressive
che prima non lo erano
oggi uno studente può creare una
presentazione multimediale può
raccontare un'esperienza tramite un blog
tramite un video una radio online può
creare in maniera collaborativa ebook
immagini interattive può esprimersi
davvero in un'infinità di modi
iperattivi ipertestuali tutto quello che
volete ma si tratta pur sempre di
creazioni e dello specifico di
narrazioni con tutto il potere
liberatorio e trascinante di una
narrazione si sa che racconti una tua
esperienza se che racconti una tua idea
o anche un argomento disciplinare ecco
che in quest'ottica il digitale diventa
un'opportunità altri diventa tante
opportunità per ampliare le possibilità
di espressione di un individuo e poi
l'esempio di prima del fumetto come
nostra modalità per raccontare un'idea
di storia sfruttando questa cosa
incredibile di unire immagini testi
segni e di rendere più vicini concetti
anche lontani o comunque articolati nei
nostri percorsi nelle scuole cerchiamo
di incentivare il più possibile il
ricorso a questi strumenti narrativi
affinché si diffonda sempre di più un
gusto per la narrazione strumenti
narrativi che il digitale rende
praticamente alla portata di tutti
adesso nel caso del fumetto lo puoi
disegnare digitalmente come ho fatto io
oppure
puoi anche non di segnare ha fatto poi
utilizzare uno dei tanti software che
esiste per creare storie con foto o
anche con personaggi e sfondi già pronti
ripeto l'importante è la narrazione la
creazione e l'utilizzo della tecnologia
per diffondere cultura e creatività da
fruitori più o meno distratti tutti
docenti e studenti diventano anche
autori di contenuti digitali
ecco questo è all'incirca quello che
abbiamo scoperto che stiamo scoprendo in
questo viaggio incredibile nella scuola
digitale come si dice eravamo partiti
con l'idea di creare strumenti in
qualche modo utile alla didattica e ci
si è ritrovati immersi in questa
narrazione gigantesca che il cambiamento
della scuola anche grazie alla
tecnologia e vi dico è davvero
entusiasmante in questo momento far
parte di questa narrazione che si sta
facendo a poco poco insieme a tutte le
altre parti che sono i docenti i
dirigenti gli studenti le famiglie e
tutti gli attori coinvolti in questo
processo di innovazione con l'augurio di
trovare sempre più un'armonia creativa
tra il mondo della scuola e il mondo che
ci circonda
[Applauso]